Olá eu sou o Dr Alan Dutra e hoje eu
venho com uma mensagem de suma
importância à medida que nós nos
aproximamos o Carnaval que é uma época
repleta de cores deslumbrantes de
alegria contagiante que toma as ruas é
crucial destacar um perigo que embora
silencioso é extremamente real eu não me
refiro apenas às doenças sexualmente
transmissíveis bactérias vírus mas
também H algo ainda mais grave o
crescente número de casos de falência
hepática e infartos que durante esses
dias de excessos podem aumentar Ainda
mais você pode não ser alguém que curta
pular carnaval assim como eu mas talvez
tenha um filho uma filha um amigo ou um
irmão que se joga nessa festa por isso é
essencial que todos estejamos cientes
desses riscos é um aviso para
compartilhar para proteger a si e aos
que você ama Pense Comigo no fervor da
folia muitos se esquecem do básico
dormir bem alimentar-se adequadamente
hidratar-se
alguns recorrem a artifícios perigosos
como auso de medicamentos bebidas
energéticas e álcool sem perceber o
risco iminente que isso representa eu
quero que você amante dessa festa
vibrante desfrute de cada momento com a
máxima intensidade mas também com
segurança e saúde se você tem alguém
querido indo pra Folia é importante
conhecer os riscos e as medidas
preventivas que podem ser feitas dias
antes da festa e também durante a folia
pessoal durante o carnaval doenças
sexualmente transmissíveis como
gonorreia sífilis herps genital HPV ou
papiloma vírus humano Clamídia hepatites
B e C e o HIV encontram um ambiente
propício para se espalhar o perigo não
reside apenas no sexo vaginal e anal mas
também no oral o risco de contágio no
sexo oral é um pouco menor do que sexo
vaginal ou anal mas ainda existe pessoal
o uso de camisinha masculina ou feminina
em todas as relações sexuais seja orais
anais ou vaginais é o método mais eficaz
para evitar a transmissão dessas doenças
agora você decidiu aproveitar os dias de
carnaval mas sem se envolver sexualmente
com desconhecidos acredita que está fora
do grupo de risco para essas doenças e
quanto aos beijos Infelizmente o simples
ato de beijar pode transmitir doenças
como herpes labial mononucleose e até
candidíase o herpes labial é causado
pelo vírus herp simples e se transmite
principalmente pelo contato direto com
lesões de pessoas infectadas como
durante um beijo os sintomas incluem
lesões na pele ao redor dos lábios
vermelhidão pequenas bolhas amareladas
que causam formigamento e dor além de
febre mal-estar e dor de garganta já a
candidi e popularmente conhecida como
sapinho é causada por um fungo do gênero
Cândida está ligada à imunidade baixa
quando atinge os órgãos genitais a
doença é considerada uma infecção
sexualmente transmissível conhecido pela
sigla is os sintomas do sapinho começam
com uma lesão avermelhada ou
esbranquiçada na língua que pode ou não
doer e dura cerca de 5 dias já a
mononucleose conhecida como a doença do
beijo é causada pelo vírus do epstein
bar e é transmitida principalmente pela
saliva os sintomas incluem dor de
garganta fadiga malestar febre e gangos
inchados nos pescoços em casos mais
graves pode haver dor nas articulações e
no abdômen e até inchaço no fígado ou no
Basso a maioria das pessoas se recupera
mas a doença pode ficar Adormecida no
organismo em alguns casos ser um gatilho
para doenças autoimunes especialmente em
pessoas com predisposição genética
pessoal então mesmo que você decida
apenas beijar durante o Carnaval ainda
existe um risco de contrair essas
doenças minha recomendação nesses casos
é uma boa higiene bucal uso de spray de
própolis Verde várias vezes ao dia e
mascar funcho ou cravo da índia para
mais detalhes veja os meus vídeos sobre
mascar cravo e funcho estão aí na
descrição do vídeo bem mas você decide
ir ao carnav Val com seu amigo ou
namorada e não vai sair beijando ou
tendo relações sexuais com desconhecidos
só quer aproveitar a folia mesmo assim
ainda existem riscos o carnaval é uma
época de pura Euforia e desfile de
alegrias mas lembre-se é também um campo
fértil para os vilões invisíveis as
viroses imagine um exército de
microscópicos invasores se aproveitando
da nossa
despreocupação na aglomeração pessoal
pessoal o contato social é uma parte
importante das nossas vidas e não
devemos nos privar por preocupações com
viroses mas se podemos fazer algo esse
algo é fortificar nosso escudo
imunológico se você já seguiu os
conselhos do meu vídeo descubra Como
melhorar o sistema imune em três dias
está no caminho certo eu vou deixar o
link na descrição em nossa luta contra
vírus e bactérias essencial ter um
sistema imune robusto e a chave para
isso pode estar na sua dieta e nos
suplementos que você escolhe inclua dias
antes da folia água com limão chá de
gengibre ou alho cru ralado na sua
rotina diária vitaminas são nossas
grandes amigas nessa jornada a vitamina
D em níveis adequados é vital pro
combate infecções a vitamina C
especialmente em altas doses divididas
ao longo do dia apenas por alguns dias
também é uma aliada crucial para evitar
que uma infecção progrida outro
suplemento que merece destaque é o óleo
de orégano conhecido por suas
propriedades antimicrobianas
antifúngicas junto com zinco um mineral
essencial para manter nossas defesas em
alta e não podemos esquecer de outros
ajudantes como ainá purpúrea usada
apenas por sete dias e o própolis verde
que pode ser de uso contínuo portanto
incorporar esses alimentos suplementos
pode ser a chave para sistema de defesa
imune mais forte durante a folia vamos
falar bem sério agora no carnaval muitos
de Nós entramos em um modo de liberação
Total E esquecemos os cuidados básicos
com a saúde um copo de bebida alcoólica
aqui outro ali e logo estamos Navegando
em um mar de álcool onde o nosso fígado
é o navio tentando sobreviver à
tempestade mulheres e homens todos estão
vulneráveis aos danos hepáticos mas as
mulheres são especialmente mais
suscetíveis muitos acabam tomando
remédios anti-inflamatórios e
analgésicos para suportar as dores de
tanto tempo de curtição e Folia e pioram
muito a situação já que são medicações
que costumam atacar o fígado A questão
não é apenas beber é o quanto bebemos e
como isso afeta o nosso fígado e aí no
fervor do carnaval acabamos ignorando os
sinais de alerta perda de apetite
náuseas dor abdominal em estágios mais
graves a icterícia aquele amarelamento
dos olhos e da Pele que grita pare agora
vamos ser Claros a doença hepática
alcoólica é uma realidade ela não
escolhe a quem afetar bebidas alcoólicas
em excesso muitas pessoas misturam
vários tipos de bebidas ainda combinam
com energéticos e com abuso de
medicações com alimentação ruim e
desidratação são uma receita pro
desastre as minhas dicas são hidrate-se
com água alimente-se bem lembre-se de
que que o álcool deve ser um convidado
Passageiro não o anfitrião da festa
Existem várias maneiras de nutrir e
proteger o fígado antes da folia Mas
isso não significa que você deve abusar
das bebidas Ok além das mudanças de
dieta certos suplementos e ervas podem
oferecer um suporte Extra pra saúde
hepática a silimarina encontrada no Carl
Mariano é conhecida por suas
propriedades de proteção hepática ela
ajuda a regenerar células do fígado e
protege contra danos causados por
substâncias tóxicas a Alca chofra e o
dente de leão também são excelentes por
fígado ambas atuando como agentes
detoxificantes o gengibre com suas
propriedades antiinflamatórias e
antioxidantes é um aliado poderoso na
proteção do fígado na proteção hepática
o chá de boldo por sua vez tem sido
tradicionalmente usado para aliviar des
confortos hepáticos a vitamina E é
essencial nesse processo de proteção a
sua ação antioxidante antiinflamatória
ajuda a combater o estress oxidativo no
fígado Além disso incorporar alimentos
amargos como chicória escarola couve
agrião e almeirão na sua dieta promove a
função hepática essas estratégias
combinadas formam um escudo robusto pra
saúde do fígado Pessoal esse Alerta
agora é muito an no carnaval uma
combinação perigosa de fatores pode
aumentar o risco de infarto
especialmente em pessoas com doenças
pré-existentes ou condições não
diagnosticadas essa situação é alarmante
sobretudo Considerando o crescente
número de jovens sofrendo infartos a
festa de carnaval com seus excessos é um
caldeirão fervente onde os riscos
cardíacos podem aumentar
exponencialmente
durante o carnaval muitos se deixam
levar pela Euforia e negligenciam
alimentação saudável optando por
alimentos ricos em
carboidratos açúcares e gorduras ruins
como é o caso do cachorro quente batata
frita essa escolha se soma a uma dieta
já pobre no dia a dia transformando a
festa na gota d'água para problemas de
saúde sérios os alimentos consumidos em
excesso durante o carnaval causam Picos
rápidos de insulina e promovem um estado
inflamatório no corpo que pode ser
especialmente Perigoso para quem já
possui predisposição a problemas
cardíacos além disso a desidratação é um
fator crítico Talvez o mais crucial aqui
durante o carnaval muitos se entregam ao
álcool e suam bastante ignorando a
necessidade de hidratação adequada
pessoal a cerveja é muito diurética isso
pode levar a desidratação perda de
vitaminas e minerais
que são importantes e mais riscos à
saúde a desidratação pode levar a uma
diminuição do volume sanguíneo
aumentando a viscosidade do sangue e
consequentemente elevando o risco de
formação de coágulos sanguíneos esses
podem obstruir artérias já comprometidas
desencadeando um ataque cardíaco é
essencial entender a importância do
equilíbrio eletrolítico especialmente
dos íons como potássio e magnésio no
funcionamento cardíaco Esses eletrólitos
são vitais paraa manutenção da bomba de
sódio e potássio que estão na células e
é crucial pra função muscular incluindo
o músculo cardíaco um desequilíbrio
desses eletrólitos frequentemente
exacerbado pelo consumo excessivo de
álcool e pela desidratação pode levar a
arritmias cardíacas e aumentar o risco
de infarto além de se hidratar bem com
água pura você pode usar o suplemento de
Magnésio e caprichar no consumo de
alimentos ricos em potássio como abacate
banana e água de coco e dias antes você
pode usar o áo que é uma solução
interessante e também barata para você
baixar a sua pressão arterial sanguínea
e melhorar também a circulação a água de
áo diminui o risco relativo de um ataque
cardíaco diminuindo os níveis de cálcio
no sangue e atuando contra a formação de
coágulos né além diso isso a água de
alho tem um potente efeito antiviral
antifúngico e
antibacteriano melhora a resistência à
insulina e diminui o processo
inflamatório portanto a mensagem é Clara
e urgente antes e durante o carnaval é
fundamental manter uma alimentação
balanceada rica em nutrientes e Pobre em
alimentos
processados isso para garantir também
uma hidratação adequada e limitar o
consumo de álcool Além disso manter os
exames médicos em dia e Estar atento a
qualquer sinal de doença cardiovascular
pré-existente é
fundamental essas medidas podem ser a
diferença entre uma celebração memorável
e uma tragédia evitável cuidar de si
mesmo é o primeiro passo para garantir
que cada carnaval seja lembrado com
alegria e não com arrependimento
continue comigo e assiste esses dois
vídeos relacionados são bem
interessantes sobre descubra Como
melhorar o sistema imune em três dias e
o que acontece quando você mastiga dois
cravos da Índia todos os dias estão
aparecendo aí na sua tela Muito obrigado
pela sua atenção um grande abraço um
beijo no seu coração Você é
fera